وكان قدر اللبنانيين ان يتشاركوا كوارث
العالم باجمعه فعدد منهم في عداد الضحايا
او المفقودين جراء الزلزال المدمر نحن في
منزل عائله ابراهيم خلف المفقود وعائلته
في تركيا
مرحبا
عيون العائلات تراقب بدقه كل تفصيل على
نشرات الاخبار علها تلمح وجوه ابراهيم
وزوجته واولاده الثلاثه بين الناجين مع كل
عمليه انقاذ يشاهدونها على الشاشات
انا شجعته ايه والله
بحس مرات قلبي اللي بيكونوا متخبين بشي
محل ومره بس اسمع هيك بيقمت قلبي بصير
قبل ساعات من الزلزال كان حديث هاتفي مطول
بين ابراهيم ووالدته
وصار يحكي لي على الوضع هونيك هو مبسوط
صارت بالليل طلع الزلزال اجيت اتصلت
الوضع الاقتصادي المتدهور في لبنان هو ما
دفع بهذه العائله الى الهجره قبل حوالي
اربعه اشهر تواصلنا مع الخارجيه حتى اليوم
رجعنا تواصلنا معهم مره ثانيه اخذوا البيت
تبعه
والاسم المنطقه واخذوا اسمائهم والصور
وقالوا لنا خليكم على السماء وان شاء الله
يكون حس على بدايه الزلزال انه قدر طلع من
البيت كونه البيت كثير صغير يعني
البنايم الف من ثلاث طوابق هو بالطابق
الثاني
يعني الخروج منا بيكون سهل كتير فبنتمنى
انه يكون حس على الزلزال وطلع لبرا هو
المنشور الاخير الذي نشرته العائله
المفقوده على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي قبل
يوم واحد من الزلزال وتضرعات العائله بان
يتبعه منشور اخر يزف سلمتهم نهج يوسف
العربيه بيروت